[Music]
darris queen you are mad
giving me a palace which is a monstrous
extravagance this is Molly we are at war
we won which is not over
we must continue oh oh I did not know
that and Queen is an extraordinary
person they were all staring weren't
they
I can tell even if I can't see and I
heard the word fat and ugly no one but
me would dare and I did not
she's been stalked by tragedy everyone
leaves me he dies
I apologize for my appearance I hoped I
might be employed here by you as
something a monster for the children to
play with perhaps it is important to
make new friends in court is it not yes
sir beautiful stop it don't you mock me
however a man I would ravish you have
become close to Abigail she is a Viper
you're jealous
you must send up again away I do not
want to bet shoot something sometimes it
is hard to remember whether you have
loaded the pellet or not I must take
control of my circumstance always favor
is a breeze that shifts direction all
the time then in an instant you're back
sleeping with a bunch of scabrous [ __ ]
as it turns out I'm capable of much
unpleasantness
[Music]
did you look at me
I could not just stand by and let you
destroy me joy it is fun to be queen
something you do not gain I will stop
kicking you my dear friend how good to
see you've returned from hell I'm sure
you shall pass through it one day
[Music]
you